things we see that we face
no one can do under the team I really
does not help a gage find at least
expose you've done it more efficiently
the hot cheerleaders seem to love the
way that we did things kids laugh hey
let's work what my Studios there that
can see conundrum
let's just talk about this to adults
over coffee or maybe dinner
[Music]
why do you think that you're the only
one about that you like to be good I
would like to say III result officials
none of us will face it
[Music]
[Applause]
simulator for my son's a hero
[Music]
[Applause]
hey youtubers is Charlie bet you didn't
think we were going to get a Supergirl
crossover this early so I'm going to
explain what's going on there's a
Supergirl crossover stuff there's a
flash arrow crossover there's black
flash stuff and they tease future flash
on legends of tomorrow so I tried to
include all that in this video but there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video this is really a top 7 but I did
it as a top 5 so there's like two extra
things at the end of this about black
flash legends of tomorrow stuff whole
bunch of stuff going on in here but
starting with number five the Supergirl
crossover you may have spotted that
they're in cat Grants office here
fighting Cisco in his full vibe costume
in gypsy so the reason for that is
probably because they both have the
ability to vibe across dimension so
during this epic gypsy versus vibe
battle it looks like they'll just be
battling each other through different
dimensions at least this one maybe
others - that's the really exciting
thing is that when they have really
quick moments like this they can tease
other dimensions that we haven't seen
yet like we can get a better look at
earth 19 they can tease earth - for the
big gorilla City episode that's going to
be episodes 13 and 14 so I'll mention
something about that again at the end of
the video that's why it's so important
to look at what's going on in the
background
when they have big montages like this
sometimes you just have to watch it a
couple times or however you watch the
video just like rewind it if you're
streaming it from the CW app if you
having trouble finding the show they
don't put it on Hulu anymore in the
United States you have to go to the CW
app to watch it or you can go to the CW
website but hopefully whichever country
you live in
you're able to find it the night that it
airs you have to wait too long but
there's a big flash supergirl crossover
coming in episode 17
they just teased it I'll do a separate
video for that eventually but it's a
little ways off it's the music Meister
episode it's going to take place in
Central City but they haven't explained
how they're getting all the Supergirl
characters onto earth one so that'll be
a separate video but number four is
flash arrow crossover in the same vein
is this really quick Supergirl crossover
so next week on arrow there's going to
be the quickest flight
- crossover that you've ever seen like
don't blink or you'll miss it but they
haven't explained what it's going to be
there's just a picture of the flash in
Captain Singh's office in Central City
so it sounds like Barry's going to help
get them some information maybe it has
something to do with the new Black
Canary or with black siren because they
haven't addressed whether or not she
escaped on the flash yet so hopefully
there'll be a moment like that in next
week's episode number three
dr. alchemy on the team and it's sort of
like a funny - the company three's a
crowd funny moments where he's like
there's like seven things here you could
have done way better than you did them
and everyone else was like well you know
Julian thought this was good so there's
going to be a lot of funny moments with
Julian budding into the team trying to
make them better there was that funny
moment at the end of last week's episode
where he had that really awkward comment
and Kaitlyn's life will work on your
personal skills so by the end of the
season he'll probably chill out a little
bit just in the way that HR has chilled
out - yeah thank you yes like thing with
my last team they were all nodded like
avatars right we need to work on your
small talk skills yeah Sean went down
for number two iris tell like Barry that
she doesn't want to hide away for the
rest of the season just because they
think that she's destined to die so in
case you forgot because they haven't
done it in a while she's a news reporter
she looks like she's out trying to solve
a case she even steps up to this
person's gun barrel so this is them
telling you the iris is going to get a
storyline that has nothing to do with
her avoiding trying to get killed
because you know what would happen if
you knew you were gonna die you would go
hide in a bunker for like the next three
months so this is them showing you cuz
that's not going to happen she's
actually going to be doing some
interesting stuff you see Wally basking
in the adoration of all these
cheerleaders that look like they're
dressed in the small bill cheerleading
costumes this actually looked like they
pulled them from the Smallville archive
and that's all Warner Brothers stuff so
they can reuse props from Smallville so
if you've ever thought that you saw
something that looked like it was from
Smallville it probably was because that
was another Vancouver show in the flash
shoots in Vancouver and the number one
big thing is this teaser for legends of
tomorrow that Barry might guest star in
episode 16 Marc Guggenheim teased and
this is
quoting him he says in the penultimate
episode we're going to have I can't be
specific about this but it's one of the
most fun things I think we've ever done
on the show a character from one of our
other shows on legends in a way that
you've never seen them before
this could be any number of things but
it's going to be a really comic book II
moment where it's from like an alternate
future or something like that because
remember the Legion of Doom has the
spear of destiny so people are thinking
that they'll get it change history in
some way before the legends fix it and
we'll get a look at somebody in a
different context in because we have
this big Barry Allen from 2056 message
they might actually pay that off and
we'll see him from that timeline and
it'll be like the future version of the
flash from this darkest timeline or just
like a really fun wink at that now the
way they word that makes it sound like
it's someone who hasn't already done
some alternate version of themself on
legends so I don't think that it's going
to be a future version of Oliver where
he has like the beard and the one arm
they've already done that I think it's
much more likely that it would be a
flash thing or it would be a Jay Garrick
thing and it'll be just the society
stuff but they didn't say what the twist
was that would cause this alternate
version of a character that we know to
show up it in say if it would be the
Spear of Destiny that would create a new
version of them or if it would be from
our own timeline but you guys can let me
know who do you think this mystery
character that's going to be this really
crazy wink at the fans and super comic
book II is going to be he said they just
gave the actor the offer so this is
somebody who's probably a series regular
on the flash arrow or Supergirl you have
to consider Supergirl as well if it is
someone from Supergirl I would expect it
it be valor with his full comic book
costume and he'd be with the Legion of
super-heroes
in the 31st century it'd be like that
far in the future but I'm really hoping
that we get to see a future version of
Barry Allen in a very different costume
because based on the behind the scenes
stuff Barry's costume has not changed on
the flash yet but it could be any number
of people just expect it to be a really
big deal
even though it's going to be a one-off
thing the other really
big thing too is the black flash that's
going to be coming to the flash very
soon but also two legends of tomorrow in
the last couple of episodes I think it's
episode 15 of legends of tomorrow they
did confirm that he be coming for ego
bars dawn so I'll do a separate video
about that for legends when we get a
little bit closer next video tonight
will be a video for all the trailers
that are going to be dropping at the
Super Bowl there's a whole bunch of
stuff well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to catch up on
the flash and you can click here for my
Snoke episode 8 video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you in the next video
you